hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round five over the 2019 Tata
Steel chess tournament we said we will
cover a game between seminal Shanklin
and England now the England is like I
always mention a very very exciting
player he always plays extremely sharp
lines and his games are never boring
even that draw against Magnus Carlsen
was a really intense game but here he
faces a similar segment who had a
phenomenal 2018 he first won the United
States Championship in clear first place
ahead of Fabiana Caruana the Watchers
championship challenger Hikaru Nakamura
and Wesley sole so that in itself is a
phenomenal feat then he won the cup of
Blanca Memorial again in clear first
place if you are interested in some
extra vast knowledge the first person to
win the cup of monkey memorial in 18th
in 1962 is none other than Miguel Maia
Dorf and the person who won the
capablanca memorial the most times is
none other than a vastly von Schuch and
also only a month after winning the capo
blanca memorial he won the American
continental championships so he really
won pretty much everything in 2018 he
also broke the 2020 702 rating barrier I
believe he's now the 11th American to do
so in history but I'm not sure about
that information but definitely a very
strong player but here he faces the
monster he faces King ding and well it's
it's just a an excellent game so let's
check it out now we have a four by
Frankland e5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6
and Bishop to b5 the rule opus a6 more
fees defense we have Bush up to a4 and
Knight to f6 this is all standard theory
we've seen it plenty of times the Bishop
e7 rook e1 b5 King the bishop bag but
should be three we have castles and this
is a well a very exciting moment in
every rule opus game will Shanklin go
for c3 and allow something like the
Marshall attack as we all know
Dingley ruin such a creative player
surely has every line of the marshal
memorized but aside from c3 you could go
a four or h3 the so called auntie Marsh
aligns and Shanklin goes forth one such
line that is h3 so we will not be seeing
the marshal attack but still it will be
a very exciting game as you'll see there
should be seven D 3 D 6 D these are all
standard moves in standard manoeuvres c3
Knight to a5 push kicking the bishop
back also making room for this spawned
march forward with a push up to C - and
now c5 Knight BD to white will often go
for this maneuver in the rule of as you
you want to go to f1 and then depending
on what black plays either 2 e 3 or 2 G
3 we have rook to e8 preparing to move
the bishop back so the rook can keep an
eye on the e5 pawn as well and now comes
nice - f1 and here the disposition has
been reached so many times there are
over 150 games in the database from high
from you know top tier tournaments and
here we have h6 nights the e3 we have
rushed back to f8 and here be for my
Frankland and this position has been
reached only once in history it was in
1964 in Baku championship in the game
Russia Desmond Dino vs. Udo which were
you - it should retreated with the
Knight to c6 but here dingos 4c captures
on before which is a better move see
characters on b4 Knight to c6 and now a3
defending the b4 pawn and now d5 biding
as you can see if you can push d5
without making too many concessions then
you're doing ok with black and here you
could trade everything let's say you
could go Knight captures Knight captures
captures captures with the Queen Bishop
to b3 attacks the Queen Queen goes back
and then Bishop to b2 you will have a
mighty bishop pair eyeing at the King
side here but there's no real way for
you to increase the pressure against the
e5 pawn so black is perfectly fine here
it's very unlikely that you will be able
to push d4 so it's actually black who
decides what what will be
plate here black and go a five and
continued playing on the queenside the
black will be perfectly fine here so
Shanklin that doesn't enjoy this instead
we have Knight to g4 and okay Dean takes
the opportunity to trade Queens as he
decides it will be in his favor Knight
captures H captures on g4 d captures
pawn captures and now trading Queens
Queen captures and e1 rook captures and
now a five again the center is a very
nicely protected and there is the
possibility of rook to d7 but the dinga
doesn't mind this he prefers to play on
the Queen side as if rook to d7 there's
nothing wrong with this move but let's
say Bishop c8 attacking the rook rook c7
and then Knight d4 black can simply
trade down create a passed pawn on d4
and continue play play on the Queen side
so first we have B captures on a5 Knight
captures on a5 and now rook the b1
leaving this option open to go to thee 7
and also the b-pawn is now under attack
so how do you prevent both threats row
captures on b5 and rook to d7
well Bishop the c6 seems like a funny
looking move but you know if it works
why not
we've brush up to c6 and now it's a very
dangerous position for white this
Knights the c4 move is a pretty big deal
for example if you try something like
Bishop to e3 just you know control the
c5 square let's say you want to keep on
developing then Knight to c4 comes with
an attack on the bishop and also with a
double attack against the a3 pawn you
wouldn't really have a hair away of
defending the a3 pawn adding would win a
pawn and then he would have a clear past
be pawn and it would be very hard to
stop it with the bishop repair so here
after Bishop c6 we have night study to
controlling the C 4 square
rook eat the d8 putting pressure along
the D file and now King to f1 you wanna
bring the King over to help out with the
defense as well Knight b7 now
Rema nuvaring the night but also opening
up for now a second double attack with
the rook and the bishop against the a3
pawn rugby 3 defending the pawn and now
it seems that the white has everything
defended
but everything is not so simple here
ding uses you know a sequence of very
precise moves to create a powerful
attack so you know just check out this
position you don't have to pause the
video or find any moves but you know
just try to soak up the position and try
to figure out a plan with the black
pieces as the one being played is really
just phenomenal so if you did it you
know congratulations for for the effort
dingos a Bishop to d7 he wants to play
rook a to c8 bring this rook over to the
C file as the bishop on c2 is undefended
but he wants to do it without wasting
time so first he was Bishop to d7
attacks the undefended pawn on g4
Shanklin defends it we have f3 and now
rook 8 to see it attacking the bishop on
c2 you don't really have a good way of
defending the bishop if you move it then
the bishop on c1 will become a bit
vulnerable so here we have Bishop to b1
trying to do it this way but now there's
a different problem now the two rooks
are awkwardly placed on light squares so
here I did give you a bit of a hint but
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the move that now really
well it's it's a winning move for black
so if we can even call it that I'll give
you a couple of seconds for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
it's really really a wonderful idea and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show for whatever reason before we
already mentioned the roofs are very
awkwardly placed on light squares you
want to create room for this bishop so
Bishop a4 is a huge threat here there's
no real way to stop it other than moving
rooks so you don't want to move the robe
this is what Shanklin play the rook to
be too but now Bishop to a4 you know
just as well attacking the rook you have
to move the rook rook to e1 and now rook
the c7 a huge threat is now rook d2 see
a doubling of for example if you play a
character's and before rook D to C eight
and you cannot prevent rook captures on
c1 the bishop on c1 is only guard at
once by the rook anyone there is no way
to move the bishop there's no way to
additional protection to the bishop so
you lose a piece here so instead Shango
in stride Bishop to a2 and it seems that
being the trusted him well not really I
mean Dean played B captures on a3 but
still rogue D to C it is just as winning
perhaps perhaps ding did trust Shanklin
thinking that now okay you can now
you've freed up some space for the rook
and B one but still rugby one loses the
bishop to c2 you have to move the rook
now comes Bishop to d3 check once you
move the King you get a bush of the c5
check you move the King again and now
you get Bishop to d4 and black is white
is lost the rook is trapped once you
grab the rook you're also going to lose
the bishop and c1 so a completely
winning position for deigned okay ding
finds also a nice idea be captures an a3
it comes with an attack on the rook rook
to be six but now Bishop to c5 again
bringing this Bishop into the game which
temple with an attack against the rook
and now this maneuver Bishop c2 2 D 3
will be deadly rook has to go back there
aren't all that many squares for the
rook rook to be one was played and after
Bishop to c2 it was in this position
unmoved 33 that Samuel Shanklin resigned
the game why did you resign well your
rook is under attack you don't really
have any squares where you can put the
Brooke you can put the rook and b5 but
if rogue b5 then Bishop d3 very awkward
well your King has nowhere to go you
have to block and then you can capture
either rooks you can capture first this
one and still this rook will be pinned
or we've already shown if you go to a 1
then push up to d4 is deadly or Bishop
d3 first you have to block with the rook
and then measure before again you can
capture this rook then capture the
bishop it's unguarded will be unguarded
this rook is still pinned a complete
meltdown for you know the leader of the
white pieces Samuel Franklin yeah I mean
it's it's a rule opus you know not not
every day will a game that comes from a
rule opus be a very exciting game and I
think this is a very exciting game it's
not exciting like I don't know maybe
Kramnik versus our universes Kramnik in
the candidates were that g5 idea in the
Berlin was used but still I mean I
thought it was very nice so I do hope
you enjoyed it and before I forget I did
prepare to find not the final but the
standings after round 5 so as you can
see with this win now adding liver and
is tied for first place with Jana Ponyo
she then we have tied for second for
players Magnus Carlsen video Gujarati
onigiri and Vishwanathan Anand then
three players with two and a half points
Sharma are of young shift of Duda and
timid raja baath then we have three
players with two points Vladimir federal
save Richard report and Samuel Shanklin
after this loss Vladimir Kramnik
B was definitely not having the greatest
tournament but it's still early he he
did have two losses one and a half out
of five and Jordan van forest one out of
five and I did mess up in the previous
video I said he had two draws but
actually he had one win against the
Yankee's of Duda so apologies to run
forest now for that Robert yeah a nice
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Martin Cole ev1 Sally
roses Adam DeRozan ski Bobby treat and
iris air is steel for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon today
is the rest day so no Tata Steel
tournament games today they are
continuing tomorrow so we are continuing
the capablanca saga and the 1911 san
sebastian tournament thank you all and
I'll see you soon
[Music]